senator elizabeth warren who is here to
talk about the battle in the senate over
voting rights legislation it's set to
resume today her fellow democrats that
would be senator joe manchin and kirsten
cinema oppose a change in senate rules
that would let this measure pass with
just 51 votes instead of 60. without
that change the bill is not going to get
anywhere in an evenly split senate it is
just the latest setback for president
biden's agenda as he approaches one year
in office with just a 44 approval rating
in the latest cbs poll so senator warren
good morning to you thank you do we have
that right this voting rights
legislation which is going to be debated
today it is effectively dead in fact it
is dead without your democratic
colleagues coming to the table look i i
am not declaring this bill dead because
we can't it is absolutely too important
understand it this way voting is
foundational that is the whole premise
of our democracy and before we get to
the procedural part keep this in mind
that state legislatures all around the
country that are controlled by
republicans are doing everything they
can to keep people from voting who are
they trying to keep from voting black
people brown people college students uh
people who live on tribal reservations
trying to keep those folks from voting
because they might vote democratic
every single senator who is a republican
in the united states senate has said
they're not going to do anything they're
letting the states do whatever they want
but you would not need them if senator
cinema of arizona and manchin agreed to
a rule change that will allow democrats
to vote on a simple majority senator
cinema says she's not doing it because
it would deepen partisanship in this
country she calls it a disease does she
have a point look
we have partisanship in this country and
that's true and there's a lot of
fighting and i get it we fight over
child care i believe we ought to have
universal child care i understand there
are republicans who say no we should not
invest federal dollars in that i get
that fight but this is about our
democracy that's the whole premise of
how we have a government is consent of
the governed and that means that every
american citizen has right to vote and
right to get that vote counted here's
the thing all 50 democrats all 50 have
agreed to the voting rights protection
bill
we're just hung on this procedure that
effectively gives mitch mcconnell a veto
and you know the thing about that
procedure is it's keeping us from doing
a lot of things americans want that are
popular across this country they want to
see us do immigration reform they want
to see us do a roe versus wade but after
a while senator people don't even hear
you now it just seems like a lot of
screaming and hollering and
i mean senator
cinema and senator manchin are also
making it difficult for the billback
better plan
so
so how do you move past this roadblock i
know you all are very optimistic and say
you can't give up hope but after a while
when does reality set in and say we need
to go in a different direction okay so
look let's do a little reality where
were we a year ago today we were still
mopping up blood and sweeping up glass
in the united states capital we had an
armed insurrection
remember people couldn't even get in
line to try to get vaccines
we have now dealt with that vaccines are
available everywhere boosters are
available everywhere by the way get your
vaccine and booster if you have it they
work
but we also passed a rescue package it's
why schools are open it's why our
economy that everyone predicted was
going to take a nosedive didn't in fact
in president biden's first year
more new jobs have been created than any
president in history so we've gotten our
act together
to do some things
that's not the headline but can we go
back to the bill back better because
just a second would it be better to
break it up at this point so that you
get something accomplished
i
i don't want to negotiate against myself
here because of course we love all the
parts to it but we need to get something
accomplished yes and we need to get
everybody on absolutely the child tax
and universal child care we no we need
to get those accomplished we need to get
those through right but peel them off to
pass them individually so they can get
through that's right but remember we're
back to the filibuster problem but
you're open to breaking it up though
i'm open to whatever's going to get us
across the finish line knowing we're not
going to get one single republican to
lower the price of prescription drugs
not one to give us universal child care
not one who's going to say that these
corporations that make billions in
profits are going to not get away any
longer with paying zero in taxes we've
got all those in buildback better we
just need to get
what we can across the finish line in
2024 should mansion and cinema be
primary
we'll we'll address that when we get
past this week okay let me ask you about
2024 do you believe that president biden
is up for the job president biden's
running for reelection i expect to
support him the his approval ratings are
some of the lowest that they've been for
a very long time i i understand that but
remember we've just finished the first
quarter we're just starting into the
second quarter here so we've got a lot
of time a lot of work in front of us oh
but you only have probably less than a
year uh before you lose both the senate
and the house all the polls
are very very very bad right i mean the
gallup had a poll recently that showed a
preference nationally for republicans at
a five-point margin over democrats you
started the year with the insurrection
and a nine point advantage in the fourth
quarter it was a five-point advantage to
the republicans so something's not right
here something that you think it could
change the game for president biden is
with a stroke of a pen he could cancel
student loan debt federally yes why do
you think that would make such a
difference because it would affect about
43 million americans and keep in mind
for the people who are dealing with
student loan debt
about 40 percent of them do not have
college diplomas these are people who
did what we want them to do as americans
they tried but
they had babies they were working three
jobs they moved and they didn't make it
so now they're dealing with student loan
debt on what a high school grant makes
also think about the racial implications
of what we're talking about we talk
about the racial wealth gap in america
it's alive and well right in the heart
of the student loan debt problem african
americans borrow more money to go to
school borrow more money while they're
in school borrow have a harder time
paying when they get out
the single thing that president biden
could do all by himself to help close
the black white wealth gap for people
with student loan debt he could close it
by 27 points cancel 50 000 in student
loan debt same thing for latinos this
would be a huge difference but in so
many words he has said that this is
bigger than him and you're saying that
he does have the power
of power be big so why doesn't the stuff
get done i mean if you look at the
polling the individual ideas from the
democratic party your party are very
popular but then you look at democrats
and often they are not popular so what's
going on here look part of it is we have
a lot of ideas and
we're out there fighting for different
pieces of this why is buildback better
so big
it's because basically the train leaves
the station only one time a year using
reconciliation where you can get a vote
of 50 you can't put things like voting
rights on it but you can put all the
economic package together but right now
the train's not leaving the station at
all and you are right on that point so
we're going to have to rearrange in
effect what goes on the train but let me
say this
offer just a little bit of sympathy for
the fact that what we're trying to do is
we're trying to fight for everybody
we're trying to fight for our babies
we're trying to fight for our seniors
we're trying to fight for people with
diabetes we're trying to fight for
people who need a government on their
side and yeah we may have tried to load
too much onto this train but by god i'd
rather have people who are trying to
fight for the american people out there
trying to do it instead of everybody
hanging back and just saying i tell what
let's cut deals in the back room and
make this thing move smoothly senator
warren thank you so much for building
our questions and thank you for the
passion
and thank you for continuing the fight